foreign
style rap that's rap that you make up
it's improvised it's not prepared we
will take five random suggestions from
the room then we'll drop a beat do a
freestyle rap if you are sat here this
section number one suggestion number one
from this lovely area what would you
like a rap about
so confident
[__] just one not not Parks Chris [__]
the way you said it like I imagine if I
asked you to spell it you'd spell it
c-o-c-c like like thick but [__] that's
exactly
[Laughter]
it's very pleasing the plosive sound
isn't it [__] great [__] that's the no
adjective no describing words
not meaty not Slender not
surreptitious oh that's not a good word
surreptitious [__]
don't want that
um middle front of the room this side I
would like a suggestion from you what
would you like rap about
jump roping thank you so much thank you
are you are you a keen jump ropist
he is a gentleman I I'm so sorry for
gendering and assuming that you wouldn't
Jump Right In the in the boxing kit
thinks they they jumped at me like that
and they they're I'm going really fast
I'm broke
like do you have like a record or
something can you do it with the one leg
every day jump rope every day are you in
fine physical condition no
that's because you [__] jump rope
that's why
[Applause]
jump roping thank you and [__]
will you permit red to give what are you
allowed to give one
okay
I should point out this is not planned
this is not the thing you usually do
usually make beautiful music
um okay yes
what second grade school teachers do for
fun you you have a child in second grade
presumably yeah
and a teacher's here really
where are you
oh
well well done for educating Red's child
so they grow up to be something more
than a musician
I'm a comedian I'm worse than that I'm a
comedian who wants to be a musician
that's me what second grade school what
we should find out from the school
teacher
um what do you do for fun and please
don't say either of those two
suggestions
[Laughter]
you dance yeah what type what type of
dance is this the 1920s
we go to the ballroom and have a good
time we flews around
what type of dancing
it's something called what
Go Noodle No I don't know what that is
what on Earth is Go Noodle
oh it's what you make the kids do for
fun
okay that because I was thinking when
you said we danced I was like that's
already weird that a grown woman is like
what do I do for fun I dance Chris
um
and then go noodle it's a brain okay
great thank you thank you for being here
red this is why we don't usually let you
suggest things because we end up with
your child's teacher not understanding a
simple conversation
[__] move schools red move schools
I was going to ask public or private
school I don't need to uh no sorry
foreign
[Applause]
I guess I guess and that was from this
side of the room so we'll come to you
guys for the last suggestion but we'll
come to the back of the room usually
people [__] holler out there's loads
of them but if you've got the one that
you're like this is the one
no no no no no no no no no no no that's
my job to make the connections
although I would love to see your penis
sir if that is
uh
solving a mystery what's the mystery
come on just mention the latest True
Crime podcast you listen to you sound
very white
[Applause]
the CH oh solving the mystery of the
Chinese balloon yes yeah topical
topical that's what we like
solving the mystery of the Chinese
balloon [__] jump roping school teacher
go noodling final suggestion from you
guys so far there's been some pretty
great suggestions and some pretty
terrible suggestions but What's it gonna
be
Lucky Love Island and bum bag great
wearing a bum bag on love Island that's
the combination a bum bag is what you
call a fanny pack
what did you think a bum bag was
yeah I should have left up to your
imagination
uh okay cool bum bag equals fanny pack
and love Island well um I would love it
if we could produce a beat let's um
let's do one well this is yeah this is
what you asked for if you don't like the
wrap it's your fault entirely we have
second grade teachers doing some go
noodling love Island bum bags solving a
mystery the Chinese balloon talk and
jump roping let's do this
he shouted out identify the Chumps
hoping we make it by himself do the jump
roping rhyming out there on the asphalt
or on the grass in case you fall that's
your fault get the balance on one leg
two hopping like a lemur bopping up and
down yeah I see your beam and shine and
got the tiny thin spindly rope a little
string spinning around yeah you really
hope that some one walks by and says
whoa this guy really cool with the jump
rope come over sign you get the contract
up you get a gold medal doing all the
double dutch I could call you up say I
got a job for you do the jump roping
entertaining animals who were like I
can't even jump like a kangaroo tangle
up with the Rope like the pylons do I
see the bird right up there and it's
amazing it's flying I'll be sitting
there glazing I say how high is that
that I am seeing this past the fighter
jets it be surpassing the ceiling 80 000
feet to 120k that's how high the Chinese
balloon fly every day where was it I
take a shinter it's down there on the
ocean in South Carolina a lineup Joe
Biden how old can you get we're like Joe
can you launch the fighter jets to go up
and do a sign Winder missile he says now
let us sit there for a little while if
we shoot it down that debris could
damage people on the ground then they
blame me sleepy Joe go get the Navy and
Marines and the Air Force get it take
the debris off the sea floor they use a
boat with the massive crane take it
there 14 miles down who can blame that's
the genuine death I did a Geological
Survey oceanographers are on their way
they say we're going to retrieve this
thing and then we'll call up Xi Jinping
and say Mr President what are you doing
all this satellite photography you're
pursuing he'd be blowing his top red in
the face like the color there of the
Communist race they say no you spoke too
soon Anthony blinken it's just a weather
balloon what are these photos of Area 51
is like nah uh you got a mistake on WE
meant to put it in the sky and loudly
take photos of the clouds all the people
around me they start moving I say is
this useful what the [__] you doing Go
Noodle why is your voice so high I'd be
dismayed we're taking a brain break here
in second grade why can you do this
please sir calm down that's our teacher
she comes out to a comedy show and when
she's asked a simple question by a
British bloke she goes yeah I take a
chance when I want a break I just go and
do a dance I'm jiggle in my pants yeah
it's not bad what do I wear around here
a bum bag look at this who'da thought of
that you wanna walk along the shore with
the fanny pack the producers love Island
they get irate they say you gotta get
naked and gyrate take it all off just a
bikini or some small trunks you need to
get there on the shore I see these hunks
who to thunk the ladies with the ample
bosom start [__] find out that one of
them's the cousin but they don't mind it
makes great TV do you understand that
the reality it's like Daniel Craig
emerging out of the sea I feel an urgent
an emergency see any guy over there you
know he got a lot thickness like a jump
rope packing the [__] and when I say a
jump rope I don't mean so spindly I mean
one really thick I want it in me I say
oh yes I want to consume put it there
now now really quite soon if I was a
lady you could impregnate me like a
wound put your big fat [__] like a
Chinese balloon
oh